hey everyone welcome back and let's
write some more neat code today
so today let's solve copy list with a
random pointer so we're given a linked
list
and so this is a pretty big description
of the problem but it's actually more
simple than that so
basically you can see down in the
example this is what you should pay
attention to
we have a pretty ordinary linked list
right so this is a node and you can see
each node has a next pointer right so it
just keeps going it's singly linked list
for the most part right
and then we get to the end right so this
is the end of the list
this is the start the only difference
between this and a regular linked list
is that
every single node has one extra pointer
it has a
random pointer so you can see that the
first node
has a random pointer going all the way
to
null right you can see that the second
node has a random pointer going all the
way back to the first node
you can see the third node has a random
pointer
going all the way to the last node so
basically what the deal
is is that every single node has a
random pointer and that pointer could be
pointing
anywhere right it could be at null it
could be at some random
node inside of the list it could be at
any of those nodes
so it has a random pointer but it also
has a next pointer which
is as you would expect just pointing at
the next node all we really need to do
with this linked list is create a copy
of it
by that they mean a deep copy so really
what we're doing is for every single
node
we're allocating new memory we're
actually creating a
new node right and so you can see we
have five
nodes in the input so we're gonna have
to create five nodes
in the output right so that's pretty
straightforward right the only
difficulty
comes though is from the random pointer
right
clearly these nodes are going to be
linked together
right in linear fashion but we also have
random pointers
right so for this node we would have to
create a random pointer pointing at null
right which is pretty easy that's what
was happening with the first node
but for the second node right we'd have
a random pointer going back
to the first node and for the third node
we'd have a random pointer going to the
last node so it's not too bad right
the only difficulty though with these
random pointers
is that take the third node for example
right
let's say we start cloning the node
right we create the
a clone of the first node then we create
a clone of the second node then we
create a clone of the third node
and you know the random pointers this
one's going to be at null
this one's gonna point back at the first
node but the third node right
we know its random pointer is going to
be at the
fifth node but we haven't created a deep
copy of the fifth node yet
so how can we assign a random pointer
before it's even been created
well the answer is we're gonna do two
passes we're gonna have
two loops and so with these two passes
what the first
pass is going to do is we're simply
going to take each of these
input nodes right and we're going to
create a deep copy of the nodes right
that's all we're doing we're just going
to create
copies of these nodes we're not even
going to link them yet
right so that's what the first pass is
going to do
and in addition the first pass is also
going to create a
hash map where we map the original node
to the new node right so we're going to
map every old
node to the new copy we're going to do
that with a hash map
and this is going to take place in the
first pass
and in the actual second pass is where
we're going to actually do all the
pointer connecting so we know that every
node is going to have you know pointers
to the next node they're also going to
have some random pointers
as well right like this is going to have
a random pointer to the last node
and we're going to leverage our hashmap
that we create in the first pass
right that we create using the first
pass of our algorithm we're going to
leverage that hashmap to
get to map every old node to the new
node so for example
we see in the original third node its
random pointer is pointing at the
original
fifth node right we can leverage that by
taking
or using our hash map we can say okay in
the
copy of the third node we want it to
point to the copy
of the fifth node right and we can use
our hash map to get the
copy and so if this doesn't make sense
yet this is just a basic illustration
this problem is actually straightforward
enough with the code that i think even
if this doesn't make sense
when i show you the code it'll make a
lot more sense because
at the base this is a two-pass algorithm
where we create a hashmap
and can easily solve this problem in
linear time
because each pass is going to be
iterating through the entire linked list
and our hashmap is also going to take
linear memory of n memory because
we are having to store every single node
inside
of our hash map so with that being said
let me show you the code
it's actually easier than you might
think so remember we are going to have a
hash map i'm going to call it
old to copy because we're going to be
mapping
every single old node to the copy of
that node that we create
so first we're going to iterate through
the linked list once right so we're
going to have a current pointer pointing
at the head
we're basically going to keep going
until this current pointer reaches the
end of the linked list
aka when the when the current node
becomes null
so the first thing we want to do is
create a copy of this node right so
we can do that with the node construct
constructor and we're going to pass in
the value of current so current.value
we're creating a clone of the node a
deep copy of the node putting it in copy
and now we're going to take this copy
and put it in our hash map
so in our hashmap old to copy we're
going to
map the old node to the copy
that we just created right this is
pretty straightforward right we're using
a hashmap
mapping the old node to the copy node
and
next all we really need to do is update
our current pointer
until it reaches null and then the first
pass of our loop is going to be done
right so remember we're doing two passes
this is the first
pass all we're doing is cloning the
linked list
nodes and adding it to the hashmap we're
not connecting the pointers yet that's
what this
loop is going to be for we're going to
run the loop one more time
setting current to the beginning of the
linked list keep going until we reach
the end of the linked list
now we're going to set the pointers so
we're at the first node let's say
of our linked list right that's what
current is so let's get the copy of the
node remember we already created the
copy in our hashmap so old to copy
we use current and this gives us the
copy node
of current right and now what we want to
do is for this current node we just want
to set its
pointers because remember we we are
required to set the pointers to create a
full deep copy of the linked list we
need to set the
the next pointer right so copy dot next
we have to set that pointer we also have
to set copy copy.random
so copy has two pointers and we need to
find those nodes right so copy.next how
do we get
copy.next well we know we have
a map that can map original nodes to the
copies right so if we take
current dot next that's gonna map us
to the copy of current.next that we
created
and that copy can be stored in copy.next
right
this is what our hashmap makes our life
so much easier right
we already know we created a copy of
every single node so of course
current.next is going to be in copy.next
except one case one edge case
what if current.next was null
what would we want our hashmap to return
in that case
we'd want it to return null so in up
here
in our initializing of the hashmap i'm
just going to add
one value null is going to point is
going to map to null so
it's pretty straightforward right if we
had a old node that was null we want to
the copy is also going to be null right
and last thing we're basically just
doing the exact same thing so
for the current node the current node
had or the original node it had a random
pointer right
that random pointer points to some node
and that node has already
ha we have already created a copy of
that node and put it inside this hash
map so we can get that copy
and then put it in copy dot random right
so
the copy node is going to point to a
copy
of that random node and that's actually
it we just had
two passes one pass where we actually
copy the nodes
the second pass where we set the
pointers and we had one data structure a
hash map
with all that said we can return the
head of the copy list how do we get the
head
well our hashmap becomes useful for us
once again
we can take the head of the original
linked list
and then map it to the copy right and
then return that head
of the copy list okay i'm pretty dumb
for some reason i put old over here but
it's actually cur
cur is the old node and for some reason
i also forgot
in the original loop we do update cur i
forgot to update
kerr in the second loop so cur is
cur.next
now we won't get an infinite loop and as
you can see this function
is very efficient 96 because
it's a linear time algorithm and we do
have a hash map speeding stuff
up for us so i hope that this was
helpful if it was
please like and subscribe it supports
the channel a lot
and i'll hopefully see you pretty soon